where is your identity
side on the
moment you also have family living there
I'm done
understand that it must be extremely difficult for you
this period according to me
leave it in the jewelry
Do you still have questions that you are currently asking?
want to ask me
before we finish the conversation
due to the high inflows it is for the in d
difficult at the moment
process all applications as much as possible and in time
that means there for you
no later than August 2024 1 decision could be me
can also do that I can completely imagine
and this is 1 latest date
but because we cannot give guarantees
I have to mention this to you
11 months after this hearing
is the syrian asylum seeker
still awaiting further hearing
and 1 decides on his assiel application